how do you know that
it's that way it's true you stop it
right now
no conga I love you
[Music]
hey guys this charlie so today for my
arrow video wanted to try something a
little bit different this is gonna be
the top five theories for how the show
could bring back Black Canary so we're
talking about Katie Cassidy here in
present-day with the team so the first
two are both Lazarus Pit options very
different kinds number five Rachael cool
lied there is more than one lazarus pit
if you haven't read the comics
there are many Lazarus pits all over the
world they've even done it in the
animated movies there are all kinds of
secret pits hidden over the world there
was a storyline even where Batman went
around the world trying to destroy them
all but number four another Lazarus Pit
option earth-2 lazarus pit there's a
multiverse infinite possibilities
infinite Lazarus pits to dump people in
it's a whole multiverse of Harrison
wells out there your fingertips
let's go get one
what are you waiting for
and
that's it that's it yeah that's it so
now what now we go get a big belly
burger number three a little bit more
fun earth to black siren comes onto the
team permanently and picks up the mantle
of Black Canary as a metahuman Black
Canary she's evil right now still alive
somewhere on earth too but it could
always have a change of heart if someone
were able to persuade her enough she
really seems like she enjoys power so
it'd have to be a damn good reason
though for her to turn sides and fight
with the heroes you can call me black
siren as I like to watch things crumble
and fall guess what your next red number
two a little more standard fare timeline
manipulation via legends of tomorrow
now we've seen Barry completely mess
with the timeline now we're watching it
happen on legends of tomorrow sarah's
whole arc this season isn't getting
revenge for the death of her sister in
possibly trying to save her so would
Jamie and dark murdered my sister in
2016 if I take him out here in 1940 to
save her I've been waiting six months to
get this son of a [ __ ] so even though I
think there are even crazier
oh [ __ ] ways to bring her back that is
just one of the really easy ways to do
it because Sarah does not look like she
gives a damn about the integrity of the
timeline in the number one craziest WTF
twist way to bring Black Canary back is
for Prometheus to be Laurel Lance who
picks up the mantle of Black Canary
eventually we don't know who prometheus
is the voice sounds very manly but that
doesn't guarantee that it's a man
homey feel in even though I don't think
the show is gonna do something like that
this list isn't so much about the most
logical way that the show would choose
to bring her back like bring her back in
a flashback or in roundabout ways
without actually bringing her back in
present-day I feel like in the spirit of
the comics you need to pick the most
ridiculous fanservice crazy i popping
way to bring her back
so let me know in the comments what do
you think the craziest way they could
bring Laurel back as Black Canary would
be on the TV show last year when the
showrunners killed her off most of you
you know probably heard they stuck their
feet down pretty hard on bringing her
back you know no resurrections no
lazarus pit they basically wanted you to
know that this version of Laurel that
died would not be coming back so when we
saw Katie Cassidy it would be another
version of her it would be in flashbacks
and be like season 1 Laurel or any other
version of her from before that moment
in time when damian darhk-- killed her
so she's scheduled to appear on legends
of tomorrow obviously that's going to
have to be a laurel from before that
time so really the exception in all this
like the present-day Laurel that is
still alive like the closest we come to
her is multiverse Laurel talking about
black siren which I feel like is like
the closest you'll get to a metahuman
comic book II Black Canary so the reason
I think that they're not going to do
that which is a huge bummer like I don't
think that they'll bring Katie Cassidy
back permanently as Black Canary is
because this season is all about the new
team so the only time I think that we're
gonna be traveling back to like
old-school comic book II Green Arrow
Black Canary stuff is in the hundredth
episode and then during intermittent
flashbacks throughout the rest of the
season so there is a new round of the DC
giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
legends of tomorrow's posting Thursday
there's a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
that I'm gonna try and get out as fast
as possible so we got a big week of
comic book stuff it's gonna be awesome
so everybody get hyped there'll be a lot
more evidence about what's going on with
her character on all the shows as we go
so I'll try to keep up with that and do
videos about it but what you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
up top for next week's trailer for the
flash and you can click down here for
this week's episode video the mirror
master episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight